[Music]
well hi everybody Welcome to the data
science hangout so nice to see everybody
here this Thursday feels like this
week's flying by if we haven't gotten a
chance to meet before I'm Rachel I am
clearly the host of our data science
hangout but I also lead customer
marketing at posit theang out is our
open space to chat about data Science
Leadership questions you're facing and
getting to hear what's going on in the
world of data across different
Industries so we're here every Thursday
at the same time same place so if you
end up watching this on YouTube at a
later date and you want to join us live
there'll be a link in the details below
where you can add it to your calendar
too but at the data science hangout we
are all dedicated to making this a
welcoming environment for everyone we
love hearing from everybody no matter
your years of experience your titles
industry or even the languages that you
work in so it is totally okay to just
listen here in here if you want maybe
you're on your lunch break or taking
your dog for a walk or something but
there's also three ways you can jump in
and ask questions or provide your own
perspective too so you can jump in by
raising your hand on zoom and I'll keep
an eye out for raised hands you could
put questions into the zoom chat at and
if it's something you wanted me to read
out loud instead maybe if you're in a
coffee shop or something just put a
little star next to it in the zoom chat
and then lastly we have a slido link
where you can ask questions anonymously
too and I think Curtis will share that
in the chat here if he hasn't
already um but something I I forget to
say sometimes but if you
are on a team that's hiring um feel free
to share open positions or roles in the
chat too uh I love to see all the
conversation that happens in the chat
during the Hangouts even if I can't read
it while it's
happening um but with that I am so
excited to introduce my co-host for
today Ben Aon CIA director of data
science at
GSK and uh Ben recently spoke at posit
conference on the Need for Speed and
accelerating R and other open source
tools for delivering clinical trial
submission so I'm excited we may get to
cover a few of the unanswered questions
from slido during this hangout too but
Ben I'll turn it over to you to
introduce yourself and share a little
bit about your role and maybe something
you like to do outside of work probably
also confir pronunciation of your last
name I'm sorry I didn't do that with you
ahead of time no it was a good
pronunciation uh it's exactly how it's
spelled um so my name is bener and CIA
I'm a director of data science at GSK um
I sit within our bio statistics
organization uh specifically within a
group called ssih statistical data
sciences and Innovation Hub um my role
is really focused on what I like to call
R enablement so I spend a lot of time
working with different business groups
to understand how they can use R for the
creation of outputs um for to regulatory
agencies or talk to them under
understand sort of what are their needs
in terms of tools and then help to build
tools for those specific business groups
um and then just kind of try to
understand like What are problems that
people encounter so I spent a lot of
time uh actively listening and bringing
that feedback to to different groups um
to help kind of solve the those problems
um in terms of what I like to do outside
of work um I'm a big Runner specifically
trail running I do Trail like
ultramarathons uh through mountains
things like that um so that's what I
really like doing outside of work I have
two young kids so pretty much I'm either
at home with them or or outside running
um you know on on some of the trails uh
around uh my house so yeah that's a
little bit about uh about
me that's awesome well thanks for
joining us Ben and ultramarathon or how
many miles is that uh so I have the race
I just signed sign up for is in March of
next year it is 55 kilomet so 30 33 34
miles uh in the mountains in near
Asheville North Carolina um so yeah it's
called the Mount Mitchell Heartbreaker
uh so I I hope it doesn't break my heart
but we'll see how it
goes impressive you'll have to let us
know how it goes well Ben something I
thought might be interesting to kind of
kick off the conversation with as we're
getting questions from everybody here
is I know that you were a consultant in
a previous role it might be good to hear
a little bit about your your journey but
I also love to hear like what was it
like transitioning from data science as
a consultant to data science in the
Pharma industry too yeah uh so how I
became a data scientist it's like it's
pretty funny um I went to at University
I studied like quantitative economics
and GE
spatial um information systems and
became a a GIS developer right out of
college working for the United States
Postal Service on a federal contract and
I worked on like route optimization um
and I was like this is pretty cool I
really like doing this and then the term
like big data came around and people
became data scientists and I thought to
myself oh wow that's pretty cool maybe I
should just do that instead of like
being a GIS developer um and kind of
really get into to data so that's what I
end up doing is deciding all right I'm
going to focus more on um more on data I
can always go back to GIS later but
really focus on trying to understand
like how do I deal with really large
data sets uh to solve different problems
so I ended up becoming a consultant um I
worked in uh commercial Consulting
specifically for cyber security clients
building out like different tools uh
platforms implementing machine learning
methodologies things like that and it
was a really great way to get exposure
to lots of different problems as well as
being able to build up my skills um for
things like I might not have learned at
school um and eventually what did I end
up doing is transitioning into the
Pharma industry through a great um
leadership program that GSK has called
the aspr program which basically looks
to bring outside Talent who has a
specific knowledge baseed and bring it
into GSK that they want to to expand
upon so my cohort of apri candidates we
all data scientists and GSK biostats
wanted to bring data science expertise
inhouse and they do do it through this
kind of three-year leadership program so
what we do basically is we do rotational
programs through different groups within
the biostats organization bring our data
science expertise and then they teach us
the pharmaceutical industry
business essentially during those three
years and then at the end of the three
years you find a a final position within
within bio stats but it's a great way to
think about oh this person has some like
interesting talent that we want but they
don't have like the business knowledge
how do we kind of marry the the the lack
of business knowledge with the talent
that we want to to build and I I think
that's one thing that I really love
about GSK and sorry to be like a a GSK
promoter right now but being able to
have that kind of space to be able to to
learn and develop is is really crucial
uh to being able to create you know
those good outcomes for the
business yeah I'll Echo what Ben says
sounds like a a great program that a lot
of other companies May benefit from too
and also realizing there's a ton of love
for uh geospatial in the the chat here
too yeah that's cool to see about all
the the people that love the that love
GIS
um I'd love to hear a little bit more
about like what it's like going through
those rotations too and and teaching
people data science I imagine you're
doing a lot of training um and what it's
like like them teaching you the farma
side of things as well could you give us
an
example yeah um so one of the bit one of
the things that came up a lot of
different times was really so if you
think about Pharma we're a highly
regulated industry um and I think one of
the things that one of the conversations
I often had with people
was well we can't do this because we're
a highly regulated industry and to go
back to your previous question about
like what I learned from Consulting um
because of the nature of my work
previously I worked in highly regulated
Industries but we were able to use open
source tools so I think one of the
things that was really interesting going
through the rotational program and
talking to different business groups and
like that was being able to have sort of
that outside Pharma industry perspective
to say like look you're highly regulated
but so is you know a lot of automobile
companies or oil and gas or you know XYZ
other companies as well and they're able
to use open source tools I think like
you might have to think about it
differently for your specific industry
but like you know if you look at like
pure counts of uh of regulations I think
automotive and oil gas and financial
services all have more laws and
regulations compared to to Pharma so I
think one of the things that was
interesting was going through those
rotations and consistently having that
that conversation that like
you don't don't just default because
you're highly regulated you can't use
these tools it's it's figuring out how
do you use them safely within within the
organization to make sure you're you're
satisfying those
requirements I got it excited by you
describing that program and I jumped way
ahead to what you learned as a
consultant but are there other things
you wanted to expand on about that um
what what else I learned a consultant um
how to tell a good story um I think
that's one thing that constantly when
I'm working with data scientists who
might be newer is like how do you how do
you tell your story about your your what
you learned during your analysis or the
outcomes or the outputs from from
something I'm sure it's a Trope by now
but like communication and being able to
tell a really nice story about what is
that you did what is it that you know
would improve a decision Maker's you
know life um is crucial and I think one
of the things that data scientists or
any sort of analytics professional has
to has to balance is like not only can
you do the technical work but can you do
the communication and can you tell that
that nice story
arc what's what's one of those
communication or storytelling tips you'd
share with us um less is more I think
like one of the I think if you can have
like uh to go back to posit conf for
everyone's awareness like if you do a a
a a talk at posit comp you'll go through
like speaker training and one of the
first trainings or maybe the second one
or maybe is just the first two you focus
on figuring out like what is your
governing idea like what is the one idea
that you want every everyone to walk out
from after seeing your talk and I I
think that should be applied to how you
communicate um with with stakeholders
less is more like figure out like what
it is that you want someone to walk away
with based out of your meeting because
if you're trying to show like a
presentation that presentation is not
the only thing that that stakeholder is
going to do in that day like they're
going to be receiving you know hundreds
of emails per day um they're going to
have to be making decisions things like
that so the question is like how do you
make sure that they they get that one
piece of crucial information you want
them to have and really focus on that so
less is more what is your one governing
idea and then everything else is just
kind of like you know extra gravy if you
can get it but figure out what is that
one thing uh in order to to make sure
that people walk away with it absolutely
I know a lot of people have joined since
the like first beginning when I say how
people can jump in too so I like to just
sometimes recommend or remind people um
if you have questions or things you want
to add to specific topics feel free to
jump in by raising your hand here on
Zoom you could put questions in the zoom
chat and if it's something you wanted me
to read out loud instead you can just
put a little star next to it and then
ctis or Tyler will reshare the slid Link
in a second too if you wanted to ask
anything anonymously as well I realize
sometimes I say that too early when not
everybody has joined um but yanan I I
see you asked a question here in the
chat do you want to jump in hi hi Rachel
hi Ben hey nice to see you yeah I have a
question regarding the r validation for
the regulatory uh submission to FDA uh
in metonic we uh need to do our
validation after we have a updated
version of our I don't know if jsk has
this requirements to do our validation
for the submission work yeah so GSK we
do R validation um a lot of how we do R
validation can actually be found on the
r validation Hub which I think is part
of the is a either a posit working group
or or is is Loosely related um so how we
do it is really kind of taken from from
there in terms of of how how we do it
the our validation Hub um I can try to
find the link off the I'll share it for
you right now y um so that's oh Conor
beat me to it thanks con so yeah so we
we generally do that we were a strong we
being GSK were a
strong um participant in figuring out
how how to do it and then we worked with
basically our QA Department to make sure
that we're checking all the boxes that
we need to hit in order to say that yes
we believe that this is validated um for
those who are not in the Pharma industry
maybe I'll explain what validation means
because it's kind of like it's an
interesting problem um So
within within a biostats organization
you basically have two things that you
need to accomplish to move assets or
drugs through the pipeline basically one
can you tell what it can you trust the
efficacy of a drug and can you te can
you trust the safety of a drug or an
asset and how you do that is you write
statistical code in order to be able to
prove that yes we trust these these
statistical tests that we've
written um in order to do that you need
to do something that's called validation
um for your software which is
essentially to say we have tested this
software and we believe that all the
outputs from this software is is is
correct um how you do validation is
defined by the organization but it's
really important for you to be able to
trust your your software so there's a
lot of testing that goes into place in
order to to get that that level of
confidence within an organization that
says yes the software can be trusted um
and there's different nuances for how
you do the testing so for example if
you're using like ggplot 2 for creating
like outputs of Graphics things like
that you can generally test it through
like code coverage as well as and like
basically doing a couple like simple you
know
simulations um and saying like Okay does
it actually create the output that we
would expect
um that we would expect um if you were
to put it you know basically create that
output so there's that but then there's
also output there's validation from a
statistical correctness point of view so
so for example if we're writing you know
a piece a package to do linear
regression or doing a linear regression
or using a package for linear regression
how do you test for that statistical
correctness and that's a little bit more
of a a thornier problem to figure out
but it tends to require like a lot of
different simulations things like that
in order to be able to say yes from a
statistical correctness point of view we
we trust this piece of software thank
you appreciate the the explanation there
too I see Travis has a followup question
around
validation yeah thanks hopefully it's
not too windy out here I had to take
your walking the dog thing literally my
puppy need to go out so anyway that's
okay I was also gonna say does anybody
remember when we were talking about all
getting a hex tattoos at a previous data
science hangout Travis actually did
that
um yeah it was F hey Ben um so when when
you validate I mean where are you all
hosting your R is it like workbench do
you run it in the cloud are these like
Docker containers local machines like
what what do you do for that yeah so we
what we do is we have it we we host it
on workbench and what we do basically is
we create what's known as a frozen R
environment which is basically an
environment that has a set number of
packages that we have gone through the
validation process with and said yes we
trust these packages um so then what we
do is then we create basically a frozen
R I don't know it's not it's not truly a
container but basically an execution
script where we can then basically just
take and install that in in any system
that we choose so the goal is to make it
system agnostic so for example if we
want to install it in like in posit
workbench on our own
internal um you know our our own
internal our studio Cloud environment we
could do that that if we want to do it
on I don't know pick your data science
workbench Domino um I don't know
whatever different things like that you
you're able to do it but trying to
making it trying to make it system
system
agnostic that's cool thanks yeah I mean
there's like two levels to the
validation it always seems like
validating the packages inside of R and
then validating the installation of R
itself and and that latter one is the
one that you know we've had the most
challenges with on our you know how do
you prove that R is actually R um is
sort of the the philos the spirit of
what FDA wants to see and um we find
that surprisingly
difficult I think they're coming around
to it though if you see some of the
talks that they've given in terms of
like the r adoption series and things
like that I think they're and also I
mean frankly if you just look at like
statistical Master's programs and things
like that like our is now kind of the
tool to use so I I think from like a
call it a culture point of view I think
that's changing pretty pretty rapidly
just because of just how the workforce
is changing hey Tim I see your hand
raised yeah just talking about the whole
package and our validation front that's
one area where uh the combination of
workbench and connect I found really
helps because when I'm publishing to
connect using packrat it's it's making
sure that everything is valid that it's
a snapshot of the packages that were
used to publish it and even though I
upgrade r on the host machine
and and deploy other other packages or
other apps with different levels of
software that that one that I
encapsulated when I published it before
stays that way unless I make a a uh
specific decision to update components
just a plug for for a integration of
workbench with connect absolutely thanks
Tim I I see prianka had a kind of a
follow-up question on this topic too do
you want to jump in here prianka
oh I can ask it if if you have a spotty
connection but um the question was kind
of like is that well is that using RM
and then I see Travis asked packrat
versus RM I don't know the distinct
distinctions of that um could anyone
speak to that yeah Tim you mentioned you
were using packrat um that kind of
leaves arum I think for the same but I
don't I don't know the difference yeah I
think both are used when when it gets
published packrat manages the the
package versions and make and does the
uploading so basically it's it's kind of
like a a Docker light for your packages
that make sure they're all all of the
RBS are there and it keeps a it keeps a
library in the background and makes sure
that everything's synced up um and I'm
sure I would imagine R in rnv is used as
well but I I don't know the technical
details of that one nice thing about
publishing connect to connect is I don't
have to it just does it on the
background but if I was writing it
myself yeah I'm sure you'd have to use a
combination of both if you weren't
packag if you weren't publishing Direct
Connect I can share a link in the chat
in just a minute about this too um but
Leisa I see you had a question a bit
earlier um about being outside of Pharma
and how things might relate do you want
to ask that yeah I mean I'm think I
think I'm both curious about just like
sort of learning the Pharma lingo which
has like every industry a lot of
abbreviations to it um and then just
really
also you know sort of trying to
understand that whole process and think
about how those same ideas might you
know even though maybe I'm in an
industry that's less regulated how some
of those ideas might want to might want
to steal some of those because it might
just be good practice in general so just
kind of where to good places to start
learning and I already saw the our
Pharma conference posted out there so
any other ideas would be great I think
at the core of
of of the Pharma world is
basically can you
reproduce your outputs and can you trust
and verify those outputs so like you
could learn you could
learn like the Pharma lingo if you
wanted but I think the core thing is
like
do you can you figure out how to create
reproducible data pipelines essentially
and I think if you are able to do that
through different methods as well as
using sort of like potentially like RM
in terms of like how to manage your
environment things like that I think you
actually will you actually know more
like that's essentially the core of what
is
Pharma uh principles essentially is how
do you reprodu how do you make sure that
it's reproducible and how do you make
sure that you can trust and verify your
your outputs and I think that's kind of
the core awesome so I have to learn
Rens there are definitely a lot of great
resources on RM if um maybe someone in
the background wouldn't mind sharing
some of their favorites in the chat too
that'd be great um but I did want to
also I put this in the the chat but also
because it just came out just came up
give a shout out to some of the free
workshops that are happening this week
for the RN Pharma conference which is
open to everybody regardless of if you
are working specifically in that field
but there's a ton of great workshops all
this week and then the conferences next
week and so I shared that in the chat
just a second AG go awesome there was
another question a bit earlier and I'm
not finding it specic exactly but um the
question was Ben can you give us a
little bit more background around your
role too and like what your team looks
like yeah sure so my role is really I
like to split it up into like call it
four four pillars of responsibility um I
have a team that focuses on building
sort of endtoend
applications um for trying to gather
insights about data related to either
clinical trials or some of our business
partners outside of Bio statistics um
one I can give a shout out to is called
uh the BPH Tool uh which is an
externally facing tool on how to treat a
certain um a certain Urological um it's
not disease but U called symptoms um so
I I'll put that in the chat um but we
built that using uh shiny uh it's linked
to like scientific manuscripts and so
one of the things um that we try to do
now is when we when we submit a
manuscript try to either submit a
interactive tool or enhanced graphics
with the manuscript in order to make it
easier for people to understand um the
the data so that's one team I have a
team that focuses on building like open
source packages one of the big things
we're looking at now is is like basian
statistics
um then I have a third team that's
focused on doing um basically our
training as well as our enablement um so
we have a program called accelerate R
which is a group of agile it's an agile
pod of data scientists and are
programmers that go basically study to
study sit with them for nine to 10 weeks
train them on the use of R and then um
and then basically leave after those 10
weeks but really set up those studies to
be able to use R uh effectively and then
I have a a fourth kind of like um kind
of pillar of responsibility which is
focused on being engaged in like data
science working groups uh and different
things like that in order to be able to
to talk about r as well as be able to
have a kind of industry standard for how
to use R for for different ways for for
clinical for clinical trials and we talk
about things that you know might sound
silly like you know how do you round in
R versus SAS and python but being able
to talk very confidently about those
differences and why you might get
differences in results uh is a pretty
crucial aspect for for our industry I
know you just mentioned the the training
piece um but I realized that's like a
huge undertaking with so many different
trainees and I was wondering how do you
scale that training out I think when we
talked you said there was like 800
traines yeah so within bio stats GSK bio
stats we're about 900 people um so what
we started to do initially was having
just
open uh in person as well as like
virtual trainings with r um so like I
think we got to the point where 80% of
biostats took an introduction to tidy
verse our training which is like you
know 80% of 900 is like right around 700
720 something like that and what we were
finding was people just weren't uptaking
the training and using it on clinical
trials and the big reason we found out
was because you would take the training
and then you wouldn't actually use the
the you wouldn't use r until like 12 or
18 months later and so what we ended up
doing was deciding like all right let's
just put all our training as on demand
like I'm never going to write a better
like intro to tidy verse training that
you know either Hadley's written or
someone else has written online let's
just make it all on demand when you want
to do it and focus purely on like
support and mentoring so what we do is
we have this like small group of people
and they go you know basically study to
study whoever wants to use r at that
period of time and we work with them and
the goal is basically train that study
team up and create them into like
Champions and then also give them the
confidence to be able to go to other
studies and help provide guidance uh as
well so we do it through that kind of
support and mentoring but we also have
like big Community engagement through
different like open forums where people
can ask questions things like that so
it's really focused on like spending
less time on creating materials for
training and documentation and more time
on figuring out like all right how do we
actually do support and mentoring as as
well as get feedback to build tools that
actually will help uh our users uh for
actually using r on on clinical trials
and Ben I I see you have a question in
the chat you want to jump in here uh
yeah I was curious Ben if you have um
other cross disciplines across GSK as
it's so large I mean obviously you have
a large enough um group you're working
with to try and ramp them up but seems
like they're there could be other
opportunities that would enhance the
efficiency of the tools and and so on so
forth yeah there's lots of different
data science groups like I feel like you
know sometimes you just like stumble
upon them because I think GSK I think
we're like a 100,000 people or something
like that maybe a little bit less um and
so you're just
like you're just like you just stumble
upon them um for Bio stats we're pretty
large luckily so we work a lot with our
bu business partners um and the reason
why we work with them is like because
biostats really focuses on moving asss
through the pipeline we have like direct
impacts on like HR or Finance so like we
have those connections that we do but
like we have a whole like AI group
that's focused on like computational
biology and computational chemistry and
different things like that so there's
like lots of different um lots of
different data science groups within GSK
um some of them work across departments
but a lot of them tend to work like
within their own Department because
they're so hyperfocused on like specific
problems that they're trying to solve I
was uh talking to someone at the
conference who works in Pharma and
hearing about some of like the different
Finance use cases within Pharma which I
wouldn't initially think about as well
yeah it's cool to hear about all the
different data science teams across
companies um at this was actually a
slido question from your conference doc
which I thought because we didn't get to
it we could cover it here um but it was
how do you think about redefining the
way that people see themselves like
helping statisticians see themselves as
programmers and using git for
example yeah so I actually don't believe
in having people redefine themselves um
I actually think about how do you help
someone like learn a tool or add a tool
to their toolkit in order to like
enhance the way that they're they're
working because at the end of the
day you are not going to turn like a
statistician
into a programmer or a computer
scientist or things like that unless
they really want to become one um so I I
think the goal is like you don't
actually try to redefine them I think
you try to help them add tools to their
toolkit uh in order to be able to
um in order to be able to use it in
order to enhance their work so like
teaching us there's teaching like a
statistician git like you have to
explain why it's important for them to
know um you know kind of the the hit by
the bus rule um if if if anyone's
familiar with that um but use the what
if you won the lottery or yeah what if
you by a bu yeah that's a better way to
put it I guess um but yeah I so like I
think it's more focused on like how do
you help people add and not necessarily
redefine
absolutely and is this the training
initiative something that's kind of come
from the top at GSK or how was it first
rolled
out yeah
so I mean it was more it wasn't necessar
it wasn't really rolled out from the top
it was more like we got the blessing uh
from the leadership team that says hey
we want to try something pretty
different um are you okay with this
approach and got the thumbs up and so we
got the thumbs up to say um yeah go go
and try this new this new way to train
Focus Less on this on the classes focus
more on support and mentoring and that's
how we were able to do it so it was
luckily it we were given the freedom and
the latitude to be able to try something
new and you know in the spirit of agile
fail fast if it didn't work but
it it has worked pretty well so luckily
um it wasn't something that had to be
top down driven and I think it's a model
that could be utilized pretty much in
any
organization um because really all you
need is like people who are passionate
about R and willing to spend some time
to do that that support and training um
so yeah I see like a pretty big
conversation happening in the chat
around rounding and can somebody explain
to me I've heard of This and like how
numbers can be different in SAS vers R
but I would love to understand a little
bit more of what that means I see a
bunch of links being
shared um in general yeah someone
someone correct me if I messed this up
um but in general um computer science
has adopted the strategy that if you
have something that ends in 05 like
2.5 um you round the even numbers down
um so like 2.5 becomes two and odd ones
round up so 3.5 becomes four um and so
what that does is on average if you have
like a whole bunch of numbers that end
in 05 then the rounding up and down like
on average doesn't really matter SAS on
the other hand is the only language that
will round everything in 0 five up um so
if you had a whole buch if you had a
whole bunch of numbers and you rounded
them all um you would actually get a an
average that is higher than the true
average was because everything got
rounded up instead of like every other
one getting rounded up
um and it's a very annoying Nuance for
um submissions to like FDA or sponsors
or investigators when they're used to
seeing SAS outputs uh and everything
that's 0.5 being rounded up they start
to question that and indeed at the FDA
if you submit something in R um you
might get a mismatch in SAS um because
of that rounding problem it's a weird
one do you have to write like custom
functions to do rring like SAS in order
to get around that or just kind of
explain it away via differences yeah
those do exist and Stephanie in here
shared a really good resource that looks
like some some packages and and other
people developed around around this idea
but yeah for sure I mean you can they
there custom functions that we sometimes
write if they really just insist that
everything point five rounds up then we
go yeah okay um and we just noted thank
you for that
explanation um yeah sometimes it's like
if something's been said like enough
times it's like do I pretend that I know
what that actually means or do we just
stop and ask
um Katherine I see you had a question
here in the chat do you want to jump in
yeah um you've mentioned that you've
switched kind of the way that you're
training from a previous method and that
it's been successful but how are you
measuring that success um we're
currently rolling out like a data
science mentorship program and trying to
figure out how do we measure how
successful we've been at mentoring this
person when we don't necessarily want to
turn them into a machine learning
engineer or a programmer of something we
just want them to be better data
scientists and data
professionals yeah so for us
specifically we're pretty it's it's we
try to keep it very simple which is
basically like how many outputs are we
creating with r and is that number
increasing and if the answer is yes then
we're hitting our metrics essentially or
is the number of clinical trials that we
want to use are in some part of
increasing then the answer is is yes we
believe that we are we are hitting our
our our our tracking or our metrics in
order to say yes our enablement is is is
increasing if you're talking about like
how do you make
someone how do you make some how do you
track if someone is improving their
skills to me that's more like a
development plan kind of point of view
at an individual
level um but I think it's really hard I
think you can only do it in terms of in
Terms if you really want to track I
think it has to be sort of like at an
aggregate output level um and not
necessarily did this person like
comprehend unless it's like at a
development um or a career personal
development level if that makes sense
yeah I think that makes a lot of sense
especially given that your team's goal
is our enablement that's something
that's fairly straightforward track are
we seeing a higher use of our yeah we're
doing the professional development part
was a was a lot harder we had you know a
couple ideas but really you know one of
those things is are they using git now
and like that's something that we're
that we're tracking as part of that
too yeah that gets really hard um having
gone through like those Wars with like
trying to teach people how to use it
like it's it's the steepest learning
curve that I think I've ever encountered
with with with teams it just it it's
really really tough uh and there's just
like so many points of friction just
like when you get your first merge
conflict and you just don't know what to
do and it seems like the world just like
will not let you merge your you know
your branches together like it it is a
really really tough thing so you just
unprotect your branches and merge them
anyway it's
fine yeah but then you got to explain it
to someone later on reproducibility
right so I see um Rebecca had a question
there's a star so I'll read it but it
kind of expands on this but how are you
like demonstrating or showing that
evidence for it working like are you I
guess to expand on this are you
presenting this to anybody as
well um what specifically in terms of I
think about um to expand on like how
you're measuring or tracking the success
against the previous
method yeah I mean I don't think we we I
mean we're not trying to get to a world
where our replaces sess we want to live
in a world world where you can select
the tool that you want to use to create
your outputs so if our goal is to make
our a primary programming language um or
a tool that can be used we should be and
there's an interest then we should be
able to see increase of the use of R so
like I don't look at as like a as a I
look at it as like you have options and
we want to make sure those options are
being utilized um and not like how do I
get our usage from you know 10% to 100%
within my organization thank you uh
Kevin I see you had a question around
the cultural barriers want to jump in
yeah sure yeah I think you spoke a
little bit to this but but I was just
curious if you could elaborate more on
how you kind of dealt with cultural
barriers to adopting open source you
know in Pharma especially like yeah it's
a regulated industry and and I almost
frame it like like was it more helpful
to show like the efficacy of open Source
or is it more important to show the
safety of it you know like or or this
both kind of important you know what I
mean yeah yeah so the the big thing that
actually was the
major
um major way that we broke a lot of
ground in terms of Open Source was
visualizations um so because one of the
big things that R does so well is is
ggplot and being able to create like
awesome
visualizations um you know with data and
that was something that like SAS really
really struggled with and so the wedge
that we actually figured out in order to
be able to start having the the open
source conversation was like look at all
these cool like visualizations and look
how easy it is to make these
visualizations um compared to like other
other programming languages why don't we
like start looking at open source as
like a a way to be able to um to you to
basically use tools successfully and
then a lot of things happen but I think
the big another thing that really has
broken through cultural barriers has
been there's a really really strong
industry call it collaboration called
like the farm riverse where different in
different companies so like Ro
GSK novaris J&J like all these different
companies are creating open source
packages for the clinical trial
development pipeline so like if you can
set if you as an IND can agree upon like
we all trust these open source tools it
really kind of helps to break down those
cultural barriers about like why should
I use this open source tool and it's
it's really easy to say like well we
want to use it because you know Roos is
using it or we've developed it with ro
and with you know insert other Pharma
company and you can say we we we helped
create it we should trust it um and and
so I think that has been one of the
things that has helped with those
cultural barriers
did did just one followup did you ever
hit a wall where like there's some parts
of the organization or some people you
know some managers who just like can't
get over the you know that that the
validation or this the kind of concerns
about about open source or do did you
find you were able to pretty much break
through and most when you needed to I
think you can break through but at the
end of the day like I I try to talk a
little bit about earlier like if people
want to use their proprietary tools fine
if it helps them do their work like at
the end of the day like all I care about
is like can you do your work and can you
do your work in a timely manner and not
have like bottlenecks with platforms and
if the answer is yes then like who cares
you know if that's your preferred tool
that's where you like to spend your time
then like I'm not going to tell you
differently that makes sense thank thank
you all for the great questions as we if
anybody feels like their questions are
getting missed I'm sorry if we missed
them in the chat so feel free to like
repost Below in the zoom chat as well um
but there was one anonymous question
that
was when we s when we say like what the
FDA wants to see like what does that
actually mean like do those statements
come directly from FDA employees or or
where do people hear that in terms of I
mean you could talk a little bit about
the FDA in terms of like I think there's
like guidance on software like if I was
Phil Baler I would like have the the PDF
up already on on like what it is that
you can use uh but I think there's a lot
of like when you submit something to an
FDA or another regulatory agency it's
like an open conversation and you have a
conversation and so it's not just like a
it's not a piece of homework where I
have to submit this at midnight and then
I get a grade there's like an ongoing
back and forth conversation that occurs
and so being able to being able to
engage and have those conversations is
where you learn exactly like what it is
that you know is needed from a regulator
now there's like expected standards and
you know what standards it is that you
have to hit in terms of like having a
successful submission or or ad hoc
analysis or whatever it might be to be
able to answer you know a scientific
question uh but it's not a like I said
it's not a it's an ongoing conversation
it's not like a submit your homework and
you and you hope you get a good grade
yeah thank than you van um ahed I see
you had a question you just put into the
chat do you want to jump in here yeah
sure uh for the different visan um uh
statistics that could be used uh I
gather it's going to be different
between Discovery and like drug
Discovery or clinical trial data
analysis versus sales or things of that
nature and I'm not sure if Ben deals
with both uh but I was curious if um if
some of the algorithms that are
proprietary could or have
been um used in r or developed in R uh I
can't speak specifically
about Basia lab um I can tell you our
approach to basian statistics is open
source it's published in different like
Journal articles things like that we
focus on like basian Dynamic borrowing
that's like our our focus in terms of
how it is that we use basian stats but
can't I don't know enough about some of
the stuff that goes on in baso lab to be
able to answer that question Travis I
see you put a question to the chat here
want to jump in I'm sorry I feel like
I'm talking too much um hi everyone
again uh then we worry I I'll stop
calling on somebody if they talk too
much okay good um Ben uh I'm I'm sure
like all of us in in the Pharma adjacent
space you probably watched the Nova
nordis talk the journey to an R
submission yeah you're not yeah yeah it
was awesome um we were all waiting for
that one and they're very open for
everyone who didn't see it about um
challenges with submitting things that
the FDA maybe hasn't seen before um
they're sort of like they submitted
several times you have was like nah this
doesn't work on my machine and and then
to Ben's point about it being a
conversation um they they kind of had a
conversation and they work through it so
I wondering if you had any like you know
just got reactions about that talk like
any further commentary you might in
color you might want to add to to what
they
showed yeah
um there were two things that I really
took away from that talk um one it was a
really similar story um we all are
solving the same problem albeit in our
different ways based off like our
organizational culture or just
organizational preferences um the big
thing I took away from it actually is if
we are going down the open source route
in terms of R and different R packages
things like that I think it's actually
going to potentially create a stronger
culture of
open-source tools because it seemed like
the and by that I mean I don't know if
we're gonna if specific companies will
be able to have internal tools that only
they can use because of the issues that
Novo had um with using their own
internal tools and trying to do a
submission because of like how do I get
you know them to be able to install this
package which might not be available on
crayon how do I be able to do this so I
think it actually one of the things that
it's made me think a lot about is like
how much internally do we actually want
to create because of like the hiccups
that could cause in the actual
submission process and will that
potentially result in like a stronger
open- Source ecosystem because of just
like just the making it easier in order
to for Regulators whether it be FDA em
Japan whatever it might be to be able to
to use these tools that's such a great
answer yeah I felt the same there was
that one part in their talk where they
where they said well the solution was
just we needed to open source everything
um and and then the FDA was happy and I
was like oh I didn't expect that um but
it's almost like a it's it's a good
advisory tip for those of us developing
internal packages at our companies um
like that may not be a sustainable
Journey um in the future when we go to
submit yeah and I think the big thing
that I have been thinking a lot about it
is like the reason why we've never
encountered this we being the farm
industry has never encountered this is
because like say SAS is your tool of
choice theoretically SAS is the same
from one organization to the to the to
the other and I keep harping on this so
I'm sorry but like reproducibility is
key so if it exists in two organ if your
proprietary tool exists in two
organizations in the same you know
version
XYZ then you kind of have to make sure
that that's guaranteed if you're using
open source tools and like from
from a philosophical point of view that
probably means we have to open source
more to make sure that everyone has
access and we don't have these like very
secret internal tools that cause issues
uh with submissions thank
you um then a question I love to get to
ask people is about career advice
they've received over the course of the
their career or have given do you have
something that stands out oh man um I
think the thing that always stuck with
me is it's okay to say no um like you
should be ruthlessly prioritizing your
time and trying to work on things you're
passionate about so it's okay to say no
to certain things if you are the wrong
fit um it's also if you think about like
your brand management it's sometimes
nice to be wanted so saying no sometimes
is is good for for that brand management
um so I think being comfortable with the
word no and is is really really
important the other thing and I think is
really important or the the other piece
of advice that was given to me and I try
to live by this value is like be
radically transparent um so
meaning no matter what just be like just
no such thing as like you know holding
cards close to your chest basically say
like here's what I got what do you have
um and really focus on on being able to
have those open and honest conversations
which I think leads to Greater
vulnerability which is like how you make
connections with people um and really
are able to be empathetic with people
and trying to understand their problems
so I think being able to say no but also
and also being able to be radically
transparent is really crucial uh work
advice that people that a lot of mentors
have given me in the past absolutely
thank you so much for for sharing that
um okay I don't want to have I don't
want to take the last few questions if
there 's anything that I've missed here
so please feel free to raise your hand
if I have missed one of your questions
in the chat but I'll I'll jump ahead
with okay I I'll keep keep the eye out
but I'll jump ahead with one I wanted to
ask as well
um I know like in your role you get to
connect with so many different teams
through training and
education um and I'm I'm curious how
that's helped you in your role and how
you build these relationships with
people maybe maintain those
relationships yeah um I really like it
because I'm able to understand more
about like what do people what are
people facing um and one of the things
that I've learned is like
every or one thing one learning I've
I've had from it is like no one's trying
to do a bad job um it's just there's so
many things that are going on in life
that you have
to people require like certain different
levels of support they all want to try
they all want to do the new cool thing
is just you know everyone's at different
stages so I think being able to connect
with different teams understand sort of
how it is that they where they are in
their point of life or where they are in
their like development journey in order
to be able to do these things um it's
really important to be empathetic and
learn uh and be able to take those
learnings and give and bring it to other
teams and I think that's one thing that
I find really cool about my job is like
being able to connect with these
different teams bring learnings from
different places um bring it to other
teams make those connections as well as
like bring what are the problems that
people are facing to like our our
different tools teams or to my other my
tools team to be able to say like here
are things that I'm
hearing um what are what are your
thoughts and I think like a great
example of This was um another talk at
poscon from GSK we created this open
source tool called slushy which is is
built on top of RM to do environment
management um so I don't know if we
would have ever gotten to that point
without being able to go out to these
different teams and like actually listen
to what are their problems for how for
what they're encountering if they want
to use are uh for their for the creation
of their outputs yeah I was trying to go
find the link to that talk but I forgot
they're not all public yet but they will
be in the next few months um Ben was
there any anything that like after your
talk you thought about oh I wish I also
covered this or maybe a question that
was asked asked of you that you had
wanted to expand on
um I think the biggest thing
is if you really want
to if you really want to enable learning
you actually need to put the support
behind it and I think the big thing that
I wish I was more focused on on in it in
that talk was you can do as much
training as you want um but if you're
not actually using
it in the creation of an output that's
that's where you're you actually learn
how to do things and there needs to be a
really robust support team behind to
help answer those questions and I I wish
I kind of hit that more is just really
focus on that support and mentoring it's
really hard to scale I realize because
it's you know actual hours and not you
know a doc piece of document that
someone can go read but that that
support and mentorship is crucial for
for being able to change and enable an
organization to to use a tool and I'm
sorry if I missed this in the beginning
when you were describing the different
roles in the team but is there like this
idea of like a help desk or Center of
Excellence or would people go for
additional support yeah so that's what
that accelerate R team is and we have
like a giant Community for where people
are able to post questions as well um I
think we call it like
are for clinical forum and people will
just post questions or post
announcements about new packages and
things like that so we have like not
only sort of the direct support but but
we also have like sort of the a robust
community that has like a teams Channel
where there's an active um kind of
communication that occurs that answer
questions or celebrate wins things like
that that's awesome thank you so much
ben for joining us today and sharing
your experience with us um I wanted
there's so many helpful links shared in
the chat today I wanted to remind people
if you wanted to save the chat there's
this little three dots in the bottom of
Zoom you can press those and press save
chat so you can have all of those links
as well um but Ben if people wanted to
connect with you after is LinkedIn the
best place yeah I will drop my LinkedIn
in the chat right now so if you have an
interest in connecting uh and sending me
a message if you have like other
questions like yeah don't don't hesitate
to to
connect great thank you so much one
thing before people go I saw Libby had
posted this week about something about
learning tidy models and I saw there was
so much interest from the community um
and this month our and monthly endtoend
workflow demo is going to feature Simon
couch from the Tidy verse team who's
actually going to be going
through uh tidy models and using that
with it team so I just wanted to share
the short
link to that if people wanted to add it
to their calendar you absolutely don't
have to register for anything it will
just be um on the pait YouTube as well
but it seems like there's a lot of
interest in tidy models there so wanted
to share it but thank you all so much
for joining have a great rest of the day
thanks Ben thank you thanks B bye
everybody bye
bye